faisons bonjour bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau de la matinale
de rtl france alors cette décision de la
junte malienne à ce qu'elle est
surprenante pas vraiment puisque on
assiste à une escalade qui est matin
qu'une escalade diplomatique du colonel
à 6 mio ita est en effet pour lui dès
qu'il ya une difficulté c'était assez
facile de dire que c'est la france qui
est derrière la difficulté est là et l'a
frappé en expulsant l'ambassadeur de
france c'est vrai que le mali est
aujourd'hui assez isolé puisque les pays
de la cedeao c'est à dire les pays qui
l'entourent les pays voisins les pays
d'afrique de l'ouest et qui ne sont pas
tous francophones dont contrairement à
ce qu'il dit ça n'est pas une combine de
la françafrique puisqu'il nigeria à
pitre est très important anglophone et
que la cedeao est actuellement présidée
par le ghana est que ces pays en effet
ont pris des sanctions contre le mali
parce qu'ils n'ont pas très bien accepté
que le mali change de pied après avoir
promis des élections le 27 février c'est
à dire tout de suite
dé décide unilatéralement une période de
cinq ans supplémentaires donc les
élections sont renvoyés un petit peu aux
calendes grecques et la cedeao a pris
des mesures notamment de rappel de ses
ambassadeurs à bamako donc probablement
que le colonel keïta a voulu prendre les
devants et désigner
l'adversaire responsable de 2 des des
malheurs du mali or la france a été
appelée là il ya huit ans parce que
parce que tombouctou venait de tomber
dans les mains des djihadistes et que
tombouctou avaient été pillés par les
jets à dist les bibliothèques musulmane
saccagé et que en effet le gouvernement
légitime de l'époque avait appelé la
france en renfort du coup quelle peut
être la réaction de paris aujourd'hui
il me semble que paris devrait faire
preuve de calme et de sagesse
diplomatique
hier la réponse immédiate et et paris
prend note de la décision de la junte et
prendre la décision des mesures
techniques de rappel de son ambassadeur
comme ça techniquement pour nous il est
rappelé est pas expulsés ce qui peut
faciliter un peu les choses et puis par
ailleurs bien sûr l'ambassade continue
de fonctionner puisque lorsqu'un
ambassadeurs et rappeler le numéro 2
devient automatiquement chargés
d'affaires avec tous les pouvoirs de
l'ambassadeur par conséquent l'outil
diplomatique
français est en état de marche
heureusement d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya
des bois pas mal de français au mali il
ya naturellement des civils il ya des
coopérants il y en a beaucoup dans
beaucoup de secteurs il ya des
militaires y compris des militaires
coopérants y compris dans des unités
malienne et puis un otage olivier dubois
le journaliste qui depuis des mois est
otage et dont la junte qui apparemment
souhaite être efficaces sur le plan
sécuritaire devrait migrer nouvelle
alors quelles stratégies justement de l'
agence malienne désormais alors sa
stratégie elle va être sans doute
d'essayer de faire lever progressivement
les sanctions de la cedeao parce que l'
isolement économique est important et
d'ailleurs il a des conséquences aussi
dans certains pays de la cedeao parce
que les porcs par lesquels arrivait ou
parler qu'elle sortait les produits
maliens et bien sont maintenant atteint
par set par set cet embargo sur le mali
donc il est probable que le mali va
essayé d'assouplir cet embargo est
peut-être que certains pays de la cedeao
vont l'y aider parce qu'ils sont eux
mêmes frappés par ricochet et puis il se
trouve ça tombe mal que la france
préside actuellement le conseil de
l'union européenne et que il est prévu
le sixième sommet c'est pas le premier
fonds en afrique union européenne dans
deux semaines le 17 et le 18 février à
bruxelles et que là il s'agit surtout
par l'économie précisément de la
coopération de du régime les échanges et
en effet il est souhaitable que ont
confirmé lors de ce sommet que les
produits africains rentrer librement sur
le marché européen et il n'est pas sûr
que les trois dictatures soit invitée il
n'y a pas que le mali il ya évidemment
également la guinée et puis depuis huit
jours depuis huit jours le burkina faso
le burkina faso on va voir parce que je
pense que tout dépendra en effet de la
vie des africains c'est à dire de la
cedeao des pères de c2c c'est des
gouvernants de ces pays là qu'ils iront
dans le fond qui doit être invités qui
ne doit pas l'être merci beaucoup claude
e pour votre éclairage ce matin claude
blanchemaison un édito diplo à retrouver
sur nos réseaux sociaux
[Musique]